and you're looking for a last-minute
Valentine's Day gift a special treat
with vanilla might be just what you need
I love vanilla
but vanilla bean prices have soared
because of a shortage in Madagascar the
island country has more than
three-quarters of the world's vanilla
fields then Tracy is at a candy store in
Hollywood to show us how many treats we
love are becoming a lot more expensive
than goodmorning goodmorning so when it
comes to vanilla
nobody wants artificial flavor they want
the real thing so at this candy store in
Hollywood all their chocolate bars use
real vanilla even Nestle has switched to
the real thing in their famous crunch
bar but now there is a shortage of this
sweet ingredient and that has become a
bitter pill for a lot of businesses to
swallow do you sell a lot of vanilla ice
cream it's our number one seller at
mother Moo Creamery in Sierra Madre
California vanilla ice cream is showered
with sprinkles blended with brownies and
rolling in root beer its appeal is
pretty simple
owner Karen Clemens says it's all about
the ingredients and how important is
that Madagascar vanilla my vanilla ice
cream would not be the same without it
yet these days she's losing money on
every school vanilla has surpassed dairy
as her biggest cost so do you think
people know when they're ordering this
that this is almost like the delicacy of
the ice cream no they don't know they
have absolutely no idea the price she
pays for a gallon of organic vanilla
extract has nearly quadrupled since she
first opened her doors five years ago
when something goes from $100 to $400
what does that mean to your bottom line
yeah well I just kind of hoped that we
were gonna make it through the season 79
percent of the world's vanilla fields
are in Madagascar a shortage there has
helped drive up the cost of vanilla
beans from about $11 per pound in 2011
to nearly 200 bucks by the end of 2016
at this price point is the vanilla
industry sustainable know we manufacture
over 200 types of vanilla josephine
Lochhead and her husband Don run cook
flavoring company most of their business
here is vanilla
she shot this video in December during a
trip to Madagascar to survey the vanilla
crops vanilla farming is a
labor-intensive process beans grow on
orchids each one is pollinated
by hand vanilla is not a product where
you can go out and get it tomorrow it
takes three years for that vine to
produce a vanilla bean the market is
notoriously unstable supply problems
cause vanilla bean prices to spike in
2003 before crashing the next year
shipments of vanilla once again cost a
small fortune probably a hundred
thousand dollars vanilla this is worth
$100,000 yep
a hundred thousand dollars and a couple
years ago would have been worth it would
have been worth probably a thousand
dollars that's for high-quality beans
which get harder to find as the price
goes up many farmers harvest the beans
before they fully mature worried thieves
will steal them because they're so
valuable
the question for businesses is whether
they keep buying at high prices or wait
for the inevitable crash it's going to
come down and nobody knows that's the
big question mark nobody knows when or
how quickly
Karen Clemens is having to raise prices
at her store and while she won't put
artificial vanilla in her ice cream she
did start using it in her waffle cones
it's just what I do it's what I believe
in and to even introduce an artificial
vanilla in my store just really was kind
of it broke my heart
the good news is the vanilla crop in
Madagascar appears to be in good shape
this year and that should eventually
increase the supply and speaking of
supply the folks here at this candy
store made some custom chocolate bars
for us they gave us a couple so I think
we can part with one and send it out to
New York for you guys all right good
candy bar for the three of us to share
thanks Ben vanilla is the second most
expensive spicy after said surprise yeah
and it comes from orchids why no
artificial vanilla got to do the right
yes great